hello welcome to the last Monday
demo obviously and obviously a demo that
whoa wait wait wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
[Music]
am I still good hi
welcome to the last Monday you remember
Garfield here's a terrible rendition of
Garfield now here's a terrifying very
different things so this is the
terrifying and or terrible one I'm not
sure which it is
um but you know Garfield everyone loves
Garfield I think I think is isn't
Garfield like a billion dollar IP
intellectual property
[Music]
I don't know what I should be freaked
out more about that there's a cat
talking to me or that you have a quest
for me
um I don't know why you need me to find
this key boy you see pretty lazy
huh okay dog house
[Music]
[Music]
I don't think I want to stick my hand in
there here I go
oh okay
[Music]
thank you Odie I think is your name
Chris Simpsons that how long is that
little creepy guy been there how has
that guy been there night more night
more before Christmas is
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't do it
shockingly it wasn't me if you think
about it if you you use your mind
if you look back accurately it was not
me
[Music]
well anyway uh thank you for your time
oh you stupid and my mom is calling me
again very strangely why is my Mom
calling me again
yes
hello my mom keeps calling me and it
doesn't go through
anyway you stupid stupid cat you were
sitting on it all along ah you dummy you
don't want it you want me to do this for
you you want me to go into your house a
perfect stranger that came from the
middle of goddamn nowhere that just
strolled on by probably my car ran out
of gas and you want me to oh you want me
to oh okay all right all right I'll go
in your house
it's live
[Music]
why oh
foreign
what do you need me to do what do you
need me to do big guy what do you got
my master has made a mess and drawn all
over the walls
what you can cover it up using the
Sprint
I don't know about this one Chief not
yet what do you mean
paint over the sigils
you got it take the walkie-talkie so I
can help you through the house yeah so
I'm sure you're helping me I'm sure
you're helping me
hello
griffald
Garfield
Quarterfield
oh
milk
I like milk
aha
yep
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the safe down here huh
oh Keys you talking this Locker are you
talking something else
oh you're talking this Locker
or not
hello stay inside
safe inside
Kitty he did everything
only inside safe
outside is dream I Miss Kitty no Kitty
uh oh is that code it's backwards
01876-01876-0187 I I feel like that's I
don't know what I'm doing
uh Garfield
talk to me buddy
Garfield
okay
nope okay is there a safe on here on a
shelf or something that I'm missing
oh here we go oh I see
[Music]
oh eight one oh come on oh come on
you serious
what
what oh oh one eight seven six that was
it
foreign
oh God oh God oh God
I'm sure this is not safe
feel like this is not safe I feel like
this is the not safe
ah I see so I definitely shouldn't have
been in there I should have been in here
got it shut
perfect easy I don't even know what
run upstairs
I'm going for it baby oh I'm going for
it where am I going TV save me lean over
there sigil
I did it
oh my God am I doomed
how doomed am I am I doomed oh God
well that's not good
paint over the sigils I don't know how
many how many centrals are there I can't
see [ __ ] in here oh my God
hello sigil what is this this is not a
Sigil
well knocking ain't gonna help you
am I supposed to have like a flashlight
or something
there's something gurgly on the other
side of this door okay but I did paint
over the sigil is there another sigil
on the ceiling or something I did paint
over the sigil what do you want from me
the damn thing
did I do it too soon did I like paint
over the sigil before the objective was
there to paint over the sigil and it
kind of broke the game is that what I
did
because I did run for it immediately
oh what the frick
I got a key apparently there was a key
over there okay I didn't know about that
what is the key to
did I what did I get I think it said key
right
what did I get the key whoa what the
hell
wait what was that I just saw a prompt
what was that
don't do that to me to me what was the
problem
there was a prompt
what was the prompt
oh what the frick oh I got a light bulb
is that what I got a light bulb
fascinating
[Music]
throw the relicans oh
what's on the TV room
all right whatever
oh that's better that's what I'm talking
about all right listen you
plop her in oh two
when the timer is done take out a little
lasagna
until then you can put your toys away oh
thanks
oh
we're
where do I put my toys
[Music]
oh boys you got it
[Music]
I'm guessing that something horrible
would happen if I tried to run away am I
gonna get something good if I do this
for you Garfield are you gonna be happy
about this also I don't know about the
benefit of dumping everything including
electronics and Game Boys into a big box
of toys seems counterintuitive also this
doesn't seem like 10 toys well this is a
nice lovely internet I bet there's some
great achievement if I go the full two
hours but uh what if I don't do that
skateboard
okie dokie then I did that uh oh what oh
there oh
in the oven put it in the oven no I'll
put it away
[Music]
I'm fine
[Music]
the dog's been digging in the yard
let's see what he's buried I don't like
your arms they have to shovel in the
girl
all right I saw the key at the end of
the hole
[Music]
oh
okay where am I
oh I see it oh I didn't see that for a
second
wait oh
how old is dark am I crazy
wait
did I what's wrong with my screen I can
see it on the recording
I can't see it what
oh what
that's strange it's gone dark again
there's a demon possessing my screen my
actual monitor that I'm looking on it
keeps going dark but on my recording I
see fine it's got like some adaptive
brightness [ __ ]
it do
on one second well whatever I guess I'll
fly by the seat of my pants I guess oh I
didn't make it
I did I didn't make it
am I supposed to be able to know where
something is I can't exactly Crouch jump
oh there we go I did it
okay
horrible
I've got mad hops this is by the way my
old monitor like
it's old I used to uh raid world
Warcraft on this very monitor
this is a pretty pretty special monitor
well I'm now among the clouds
[Music]
what in the I'm falling down I'm back
I don't know what happened
but you know not bad I'm not gonna lie
pretty cool if you think about it and
I'm not thinking about it because
thinking about it makes my brain hurt
boy I hate collectibles
am I dead I mean I clearly I'm in some
kind of a hell
oh I did it
here you go Garfield
the garage
[Music]
I'll take this
go dig up whatever the dog is buried in
the yard you got it Garfield oh kind of
laggy out here hi how you doing oodles
all right
[Music]
ball
it's a ball it's
[Music]
it's a ball hey do you know your dog
house is kind of haunted did you know
that did you know that OD
oh D bone
newspaper
blood
oh hey what's wrong buddy you okay there
about
you look a little
oh
our new oh
I found out someplace quiet you said
how long are we staying here
how long was I out
it's all good don't worry about it I'm
gonna take a look around oh gasoline
I'll take that
wow wow oh wire cutters wow
oh
gun coming
oh hey oh that's the okay that's the
garage
all right meat snack
sounds pretty good
no piss bucket
hey paw
good good great
this place is this
it's ours now
nobody is coming back here
what
did you make me do this time silence
hello
is that a door opening in here or oh I'm
in the bathroom
I'm naked
I'm naked
I think I oh I had to remove your tongue
oh I see
[Music]
I'm right real yourself a reminder to
remember your place
I am not the man get dressed well I
don't wanna
but what if I don't wanna
wire cutters I'll take those thank you
get in the car
what happened I missed it it went dark
did it just go dark or was there a
secret message written in the Darkness
so what am I doing
cut the phone
but but why also how do I do that I
don't really know
how many people have phone lines anymore
so I don't really know how to do that
I don't know how do I am I inside is
there like some outside box for the
phone line
do I do the
telephone pole out so I don't know
I don't I don't know
do I
oh
yeah
silence the dog
snack okay that's okay
perfect
perfect okay what not as perfect
less perfect
a lot less perfect
a lot less perfect uh very unperfect
oh
am I hiding is that what I'm supposed to
be doing oh God
oh well that's not good
oh that's not good
[Music]
now is always a dick move Alex Craig
thank you for being a jerk and ending
this on a jump scare well done though
fascinating experience a lot of
bamboozles across the board a lot of
spooky
very nice but it is lixian that ends
these things with a jump scare
[Music]
foreign
[Music]